well I guess my biggest failure was not
getting reelected and I learned two
things one is that you ought not to have
let American hostages be held for 444
days in a foreign country without
extracting them I did the best I could
but I failed and I think another lesson
I learned is I should have paid more
attention to the organization of the
Democratic Party I was not only the
leader of our nation but I was also the
leader of the Democratic Party and I
think I failed in that respect to keep
the party United it was divided in my
relation campaign between me and the
people who were loyal to Santer Ted
Kennedy and then that cost me a lot of
votes so those were the two things that
I believe that could have been done
better